y bueno qué podemos decir entonces de eh
esta ausencia de palabras o por parte de
bolsonaro hasta esta hora puede suceder
cualquier cosa en los próximos minutos
Eduardo Sí si yo pudiera
adivinar seguro el el comité de de
bolsonares está decidiendo la mejor
manera de no aceptar las elecciones el
resultado básicamente esto es
Déjame explicar una cosa Antes el plan
de bolsonaro no fue ganar en el voto el
plan a era dar un golpe
intentó hacer las chispas para hacer el
fuego aparecer no alcanzó sobró el plan
de que era el plan de urnas atacó las
urnas electrónicas sin ninguna razón
desde cuatro desde hace cuatro años
aunque fuera favorable a las obras de
electrónicas cuando ganaba sus
elecciones como representante antes
y y uso toda la máquina podría para yo
yo imagino también que debe ser muy
sorpreso porque siempre tenía una
creencia de que lulagan a la izquierda
ganaba por temas como los giros
financieros que las familias pobres
recibían dio un giro financiero
brutalmente más alto en los tres meses
alrededor de las elecciones y Perdió o
sea yo me imagino ni siquiera está
entendiendo como pudo perder las
elecciones Entonces no están decidiendo
la mejor manera de intentar negar los
resultados de las elecciones Esta es mi
opinión vamos a ver lo que espero que me
sorprenda positivamente y que lo acepte
bien puede ser muy saludable para la
democracia brasileña que ese sea el
escenario que acepte la derrota a ver he
perdido en estas elecciones muy estrecho
al margen lo recordamos 50,90% para Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva son 60 millones de
votos a favor del candidato del pts el
nuevo presidente electo por los
brasileños Yair bolsonaro con el 49,10%
son 58 millones 203 mil votos a favor
esto es teniendo en cuenta que ya está
el
99,99% de las urnas escotadas de los
votos contabilizados por parte del ts